[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: OK, so,
the rough patch.
Why do they call
it the rough patch?
Is there a rough patch
in every marriage?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
Simple answer, yes.
More than one, usually.
I named the book "The Rough
Patch," which is obviously
a very common term.
It's not only applied to
what I'm writing about.
Because what I was noticing
in my practice as I see
couples and individuals
was people having the sense
that they had
created their life.
They had partners, they had
houses, they had children,
they had a structure.
But that sometime in
the middle period,
they were finding
themselves feeling
kind of lost, or
confused, or stuck,
or feeling that something
about their emotional life
wasn't working.
So that's what I
use the time for.
But the book is structured
so that each chapter
is about a different
kind of rough patch,
or a crisis, or a struggle.
So there's a chapter
on money issues.
There's a chapter on affairs.
There's a chapter
on alcohol use.
Different things that people
confront over the course
of a long relationship.
SPEAKER: And so are
these the types of topics
that are covered in the book?
Are they changing over time?
Or are they the same
problems that our parents
have dealt with, and our
grandparents dealt with?
Or is there something
different now?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
Well, I think
people now live longer
than our parents
and our grandparents did.
So people are trying to have
close relationships over longer
lives.
And our model of marriage
has also changed.
In other words,
it used to be more
of an economic arrangement.
In the '60s, it was more kind
of find yourself arrangement.
Now, it's more of
a how can we have
a close, intimate
partnership that helps
carry us through and support
each other in that process.
And so the model has changed,
and our life span has changed.
So that's a fact
of living today.
There were obviously
the timeworn problems
that people have
in relationships
in terms of emotional
communication
and the other things
I've mentioned.
I think a couple things
that probably all of you
can relate to that
are new and different
are the way in which
technology has completely
seeped into every
aspect of our lives,
and all the possibilities
for connecting that have
been created by social media.
And my understanding of
that is it's new and old.
I mean, it's a new way in
which we deploy our time.
But it's also often used
in very common ways, namely
to disconnect, to avoid
difficult emotional situations,
to have a moment of
escape and privacy.
All the things that
people are always
trying to balance
in marriage anyway.
SPEAKER: What about
the trends in terms
of when people are
having children,
or kind of some of
the historical gender
roles in relationships?
Are those complexities as well?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Right,
so a couple of things
are really interesting
about that.
One is that, if you look at
the statistics on longevity
of marriage now, the people
who are staying married and not
getting divorced are
people who have education
and economic resources.
Which makes a lot of sense,
because often they have
fewer stresses in their lives.
They have fewer
economic stresses.
They have more opportunities.
It also usually means that it's
a more egalitarian marriage.
Whereas in the past, and even as
recently as the '60s and '70s,
women's education was actually
a risk factor for divorce.
Now, it is a protective
factor for marriage.
So in other words, you can see
that an egalitarian marriage
tends to offer certain
opportunities for collaboration
and partnership.
Of course, it also
means we're all
taking all roles, all the time.
So everybody is trying to be
a full partner in every way.
Work, child care, money,
household chores, et cetera.
So that means a lot
of collaboration,
a lot of negotiation,
a lot of conversation,
and often conflict around
division of labor, fairness,
who does what,
that sort of thing.
SPEAKER: And so,
talking about children,
how are children
hard on a marriage?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
Right, so children
are known to be one of the
hardest stresses on a marriage.
Obviously, it's one of the
reasons people get married.
It's one of the reasons
people want to stay married.
Having a family is
a high aspiration
for many, many people.
But the research
does unequivocally
suggest that when you
have your first child,
your marital
satisfaction goes down.
And the way I think
about that, because I
teach a class to young
parent-- well, not so young.
I live in the Bay
Area, and I teach
a class for people who are
about to have their first child.
And it's basically how to keep
a couple relationships strong
when you have a child.
This demographic may
be similar to that one.
The people's big worry is
I've had this great life,
I've you know done
all this cool stuff,
I'm a fully formed individual.
We have this great partnership.
Is this kid going to kind
of ruin everything, right?
I mean, that's a
whole different model
from when people had their
kids that 21, 22, 25, whatever.
And so there is this
feeling that children
are going to disrupt my life
often with people today.
But the way I think they
do disrupt your life,
because I think we can all
agree children are wonderful,
but that it depletes resources.
That it's basically more
people that everything
has to go around.
So if you think of that
certainly economically but also
emotionally and time-wise.
And so I think what
happens with children often
is that the do-list and the
hierarchy of things that
have to happen, your emotional
needs and your need to connect
goes lower, lower,
lower on the list.
Because, of course, there
are important things
to take care of.
And as a mature,
functioning adult,
you have to take the kids
first, the job second.
And so it's this sort
of subtle demotion
that starts happening
about the relationship.
And I think people try
really hard to work on that.
But what's so tricky about it is
that the emotional relationship
is something that is
complex, is messy.
Emotions are inconvenient.
You might feel things.
You might feel angry
or sad or disconnected,
and need to actually take
time to talk about that
and sort it through.
And that's exactly what
people are missing,
is the time to do it.
So that just takes
its toll over time.
SPEAKER: I imagine too that
things like sleep deprivation
probably play into it, at least
in my own personal experience.
And things like wanting to
have those conversations,
but maybe not in front
of the children, right?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Right.
Less time alone, obviously.
Sleep deprivation is
murder for your moods,
for your sense of resilience.
All your worst qualities
just are totally on display.
So yeah, all of that.
SPEAKER: So then a
once-a-week date night
will fix it all, right?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
Yeah, of course, yeah.
Now, one thing I
do tell couples,
which sounds
incredibly pragmatic,
but I think it really can help--
part of the problem with date
night, which I write
about in the book,
is that what you want
on date night is fun.
You want romance, you want fun.
You want not to be worrying
about the kids' problems
all the time.
And that can be hard,
because if that's
that top stress on your mind
and your only time to talk,
it's like, well, now's the time.
But I recommend that people
decide on a time of the week,
like 8 o'clock Tuesday morning.
That's not when you're
about to try to go to sleep.
going to try to have sex.
It's not on your date night.
And it's like, let's just
take a minute to check in.
How's the division of labor?
How are you feeling
about our relationship?
Just sort of almost
like a meeting.
Because what I find is
so pernicious in couples
over time, because--
and this book is really
about this thing, which
is that our emotional
life is who we are,
and our relational
life is who we are.
And yet it sort of gets put
on the sidelines, right?
And so easily in terms
of all our other roles.
And so I think that it can be
very hard to be the person who
has to bring up
the conversation,
or has to be the person
to say, let's talk.
Some people are
like, ah, no, no,
I don't want to talk, right?
So if you know that it's
Tuesday morning at 8:00
that you're going to
have this back and forth,
it can take the pressure
off of one person
to be the initiator
of discussion.
SPEAKER: Or when your spouse
hears, hey, we need to talk,
that they don't start having a
panic attack because it's bad.
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
Right, exactly.
Everybody knows, 8 o'clock
Tuesday morning, we're
going to touch base.
SPEAKER: So you
talked about having
more resources can actually
contribute to better outcomes.
So then, how can money be
such is such a problem?
If you have more money,
isn't that better?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
It's certainly better
than not having money, right?
I mean, again, on this sort
of two Americas thing where
people with education
and economic resources
are doing better in
terms of their marriage
than people, that's sort
of the rich get richer,
and the poor get poorer.
That's the America we live in.
So people who are the
poorer and less educated
part of the demographic tend
to not get married as much,
not stay married instead of
marrying more often, et cetera.
And obviously, economic stress
is a huge, difficult thing
when you have it.
But just like everything else,
it reminds me of the fact
that people come into couple
therapy, and they say,
I can't believe we're fighting
about the toothpaste tube,
or who takes out the trash.
This is so trivial,
it's so stupid.
Why are we fighting
about these things?
But of course, life
is those things,
and it's this constant
navigation of those things.
And money is a
really charged issue,
even if you have a lot of it.
Because I believe the
reason it's a charged issue
is because it so close to
our primal sense of survival
and identity.
Especially in this
country, perhaps,
but how you spend money,
what money you have,
where you're allocating it is
very close to people's sense
of who they are.
And so in a marriage, the ideal
picture of marriage in my mind
is there's one individual,
another individual,
and together, you
create this thing.
This living, breathing
organism called the marriage.
And so it's not just what do
you want, what do you want?
Oh, if you get what you want,
I don't get what I want.
It's what does the
marriage need, what
does the family need,
what do we need together
to make this thing that
we're creating together?
And I think money
lends itself to a sort
of zero-sum mentality, where
people are kind of, if you
get yours, I won't get mine.
And it breaks down very quickly.
SPEAKER: So are
you of the opinion
that all marriages can work?
All marriages can be made
to be good marriages?
Or are there situations
where you kind of
need to know when to say when?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: So when
I started writing this book,
I had the hope, I
had the thought,
that if people work
enough on themselves,
they can work out
their relationship.
Because I felt in my work,
one of the things you run up
against a lot of times when
a couple's having problems
is they come in, and each one
wants you to fix their partner
and make them a better partner.
But it's very, very
hard for people
to really take
stock of themselves
and think, what am I
contributing to this?
So part of the work
of a couple therapy
is you're both creating this.
You're both taking a role.
So I sort of had this
somewhat hopeful, I guess,
idea that if people really
grappled with their own stuff,
that they can come to the
relationship on a better
footing, and they will be in far
better position to work it out.
All of which I still agree with.
But I do believe also that some
marriages are, in some sense,
fatally flawed.
And I think part of what
"The Rough Patch" is
about-- the book is about,
the thinking is about--
is how do we figure that out.
SPEAKER: And so taking
stock of yourself
and personal accountability
for improvement,
is that what you refer
to in the book as guts?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
That's an aspect of it.
I think people have the illusion
that if the relationship's
working well, it's
peaceful and serene.
And I don't think that.
I've been married
for 26 years, and I
would say every day we have some
kind of difficult conversation.
Not necessarily about our
relationship with each other,
but one about the kids,
or one about something
we have to solve.
And I talk about
guts because I say
it's always going to
take courage to have
the difficult conversations.
The fascinating thing
about being a human,
and this has really come
through with attachment research
in the last 30
years, is we never
get over being
dependent and attached.
It's not OK that my husband
said I love you yesterday,
or last week, or
said goodbye then.
He has to keep doing it.
In other words, you keep have
to feel that the person keeps
turning toward
you and giving you
appreciation, and gratitude,
and affection, and warmth.
That's never done.
And so I sort of
feel like, similarly,
the hard conversations
are never done.
If you're trying to
get through life,
if you're trying to figure
out are we going to retire,
what's our budget like, are
we drinking too much, how's
our sex life, all
these things are not
going to be easy to talk about.
They're actually
vulnerable to talk about.
And I sort of want to help
people shift their paradigm.
It's a good day for you
if they have the guts
to talk about the hard things.
SPEAKER: And so you
have part in the book
that you talk
about where you say
that you need to get a life.
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER: Can you explain?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Yeah.
So this book is about how do
you have a close relationship
over a long life.
And I think sometimes people
have the notion that in order
to get along with another
person over a long time,
you sort of have to
suppress yourself,
or somehow just adapt yourself.
And I really believe
that it's only
going to work if you feel you
can keep developing and growing
as an individual,
that you bring more
and more into the partnership.
And I think sometimes
people feel--
I was just talking
to a friend yesterday
whose husband is a doctor,
and he had all this training.
And the whole family
life was really
geared around his life
and his profession.
And she said, it's
been so hard for me
to sort of step out
of that and realize
I need to start having a
voice and assert what I want.
And we're always
trying to balance that.
How much we have to compromise?
How much do we have to
suppress in order to get along?
But I really think,
over the long haul,
suppressing yourself isn't
going to do the trick.
You have to be developing
yourself and evolving yourself.
And maybe that's going to mean
saying, look, I'm changing.
And the way it was 10 or 20
years ago or five years ago
isn't going to work for me.
Sometimes people
get upset that they
feel their spouse has
changed the contract on them,
and we agreed under
these circumstances.
And now, how can you
suddenly want this?
And in my view, it's like,
of course that happens.
Time's passing.
You're growing, you're changing.
And so my idea of
get a life is you
have to sort of bring a
lot of yourself to this,
and you have to keep
developing yourself.
And that can always be a
kind of messy balancing act.
SPEAKER: And so the old
adage about how marriages
work, and it takes work
to make a marriage.
You kind of challenge the idea
of what "work" means in that.
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Can you describe it?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: So there
is this idea marriage is work,
and everybody rolls their eyes.
It's like, ugh.
What I see as the
work of marriage
is being open and
emotionally vulnerable.
That's the work.
It's hard to show up every day
and be honest, and say where
you're at, and
express your feelings
and communicate about them.
And I happen to
believe that it's not
a tenable stance in
a marriage to say,
I don't like to
talk about feelings.
Basically, you may not like
to talk about feelings.
You may be a person who finds
it hard to talk about feelings.
It may be that you feel you're
a person who's not an expert yet
at talking about your feelings.
But the job, the work, is
to cultivate the ability
to know how you feel,
and to express it.
And that's not easy.
And every day, you
wake up, and it's like,
gee, the easy thing to do
would be to watch my shows,
and get on my phone, and go
work out, and not really deal
with this other complicated
person who wants things
from me, and I want things from,
and I can't really figure out
how to get along with.
Your job is to go
like, no, my job is
to keep trying to turn
toward this person,
keep trying to figure
out the relationship,
keep trying to be close.
That's not easy.
SPEAKER: How do things like
communication differences
in style and things--
one example being that
somebody may simply
be wanting to talk about what
they're thinking or feeling,
and the other person
thinks they're being
asked to solve the problem.
How do you overcome
those kinds of things
in that work to stay open?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Well, so
it's a complicated question.
But I'll just say one thing
about it, which is in, I think,
chapter 3 or 4 of the book.
I use this phrase called
feeling with and thinking about.
And it comes out of
a whole tradition
of psychological research
that you can read more about
if you're interested.
But basically, we've
all had that experience
of being in a couple situation,
and one person coming home,
just trying to pour
out their feelings
and talk about what
happened, and sort
of process their emotion.
The other one saying, well,
let me roll up my sleeves
and help you solve the problem.
And then the first
person is like, I don't
want you to solve my problem.
I just want you to listen to me.
So I believe that in
a loving relationship,
if you look at
emotional communication,
it has two parts.
It has you feel with the person,
and you think about the person.
And so you both have the
experience of saying,
oh, I'm listening to you.
I'm trying to
understand how you feel.
empathize with you.
Or you had a
horrible day, and I'm
trying to listen
and support you.
And then there's-- let
me think about you.
Let me think about the problem,
let me help you solve it.
Do you want to help solve it?
And sometimes
couples break down.
Sometimes it's
along gender lines,
sometimes the
roles are reversed.
But basically, it's like
one person's fixing,
and the other person's
just wanting empathy.
So I think everyone should
be cultivating the ability
to both feel with
and think about.
And love is expressed
through that combination.
SPEAKER: So if you
could give everyone
one thing to either go back
and think about or practice
at home tonight, what
would that first step be?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
OK, so I think
there's two things that
are kind of, in my mind,
the wonder drug of marriage.
Basically, you can
take two relationships
that are identical in all
their different problems
and dysfunctions.
But if in one situation the
partners are able to say,
I'm aware of my part in this,
and I'm trying to change.
So in other words, what
I call it in the book
is self-awareness and
self-responsibility.
So what I mean by
that is, if you
can look at what you're doing
together and really say,
I know I have a part in this.
I'm trying to understand
what I'm doing,
and I'm sorry if it
bothers you or whatever,
and I'm trying to change.
That is the key element.
Everything else can be equal.
But if people can do that, if
they can look at themselves
and take account
of their behavior,
and then be
responsible about it,
no matter what
they're doing, that
is just the critical
difference that gives people
hope or hopelessness.
If you're married to a person
where the story always is,
it's your fault
that I'm doing this.
If you would just change,
I would be different.
That creates a very corrosive,
toxic, hopeless atmosphere.
So that's the one
thing I would say.
SPEAKER: OK, you have
your marching orders.
We are going to take questions.
Because we are recording
this, please make sure
that you make your
way to the microphone
if you would like to
ask questions today.
I'll talk about one
more thing here,
and then we'll go ahead and
take questions from the mic.
I keep waiting for
the age of my children
to arrive where it gets easier.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, OK.
And what I get is
this kind of reaction,
especially from people
whose kids are older.
They're like, no, it's not
easier, it's just different.
And so navigating those
changes over the years,
the medication's got
to evolve too, right?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
Well, it reminds
me of when you have
really little kids.
You're like, someday
this will be over.
They'll be in school.
SPEAKER: That's what I thought.
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: My
kids are 25, 21, and 19.
And every day, we're
worrying about something.
And every day, we're having our
conversations about what should
we do about it.
Swearsies.
So it doesn't ever go away.
But there's a
gratification in actually
being able to talk in a
productive and collaborative
way.
That's kind of the hope, right?
So yeah, the physical
exhaustion, I would say,
changes.
But there's always something.
The stakes only get higher.
Now we're worrying about,
can they support themselves,
and will they find
happiness and love?
SPEAKER: Or we're worrying about
our parents and the decline
that happens there, right?
So you get out of one
situation, and you
start to take on another.
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
And one thing I
say, because I have a
chapter on the empty nest,
which I've just become one of.
And I say it's OK
to be a beginner.
When you first have a
child, you're a beginner.
When you first have no kids
at home, you're a beginner.
Like, what do we want now?
Who are we?
What are we doing?
I think sometimes we
feel, by that age,
we should know what's going on.
And I think life's
not like that.
You're always learning.
SPEAKER: Are there any
additional considerations
or tips for when you go through
really big life changes?
Whether it's a change
in career, or you're
moving to a completely different
place, or you've lost a parent?
The big, big life changes
where one or the other partner
may not be on their best.
So what other things
can people throw in
to help through those patches?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: I think
there's a couple of things.
I think one is to keep
reaching out toward each other,
but to respect what
the other person needs.
And that can be hard
sometimes, because sometimes
if your partner has
gone through something,
they're very absorbed,
and they're not
that available to you, and
you feel kind of deprived.
But part of the thing is
to keep offering support.
The other is to sort
of accept that--
I talk about this with the
metaphor, the golden ring.
But the point is that you're
standing next to each other,
looking at life, and trying
to help each other through.
And there are going
to be these things.
And so to be able to just accept
that there are going to times
when you're not available to
each other, when one of you
is terribly sad, end and to
sort of understand that that's
kind of part of the deal.
But I do want to say,
and I talk about this,
and I have a chapter called
Lovesickness and Longing
about people who sort of have
these very absorbing crushes,
even if they're happily married.
And one of the
things I've noticed
about that in my own clinical
work-- it's anecdotal,
but I'm really interested
in studying it further--
is I think when people
go through a big loss
of some kind, maybe lost a
parent, maybe lost a job,
maybe their child
has a big problem,
it depletes son and sort
of hollows them out.
And sometimes then
they will they
try to grab something in the
world that will excite them,
that will distract them.
And so I think also just to
know your own vulnerability
and the vulnerability
of your partner
when you're going through
something very devastating.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any advice or thoughts
on being in a relationship
with someone who
has either significantly less
or orders of magnitude more
income and wealth?
And I'm asking for a friend.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: I suspect there
will be a lot of that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Wow,
that is so interesting.
In my own experience,
you realize
in adult life you often
end up around people
about your level of wealth,
because it's not uncomfortable.
You sort of know what
everybody can do.
But my best friend from high
school is extremely wealthy.
And so that's sort of my
only real-- it's fascinating.
I haven't given much
thought to that.
I mean, can you
say anything else
specific about the struggle
or the difficulty there?
AUDIENCE: Er.
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Do
you want me to make it up?
AUDIENCE: I'm going to
go sit down, actually.
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: I mean, OK.
So one thing I could
imagine coming up,
which comes up with my
friend, is she's like, hey,
let's have a spa weekend.
Well, I can't afford
the spa weekend.
So it's like, are you paying?
And then in a couple, I would
imagine, they're sort of like--
what are the feelings around
one person having all this money
that they can sort of fund
things that can't be equitable,
right?
Now, what I do and my friend is
she gets this huge spa weekend,
then I buy the pizza
on the way to the spa.
So I guess there's going
to be some discussion.
Money is obviously a
huge, hot-button issue,
and there's a whole
50-page chapter on it.
But there's got to be
some discussion of what
the understanding
is there, I think,
because I think this
stuff's so complicated
to talk about, we're all so
bad at talking about money,
that I think the main
advice I would have is make
it an explicit conversation.
Now, that doesn't mean
everybody is going
to know what their feelings
are, because it's an incredibly
confused area for people,
and very conflicted,
and very complicated.
But at least to
be having the sort
of conscious, explicit
conversations of,
you have this, I have that.
How are we going to do this
so everyone feels fair?
I'll just say one other thing.
I think one of the very
most important things
in a long-term relationship is
a sense of fairness and justice.
And if people start
feeling that's not working,
it's very corrosive to the bond.
So I think you have to try
to understand what does
the money mean to each person.
To what extent do they feel
you're kind of freeloading?
Even if they don't want to
feel that, they kind of do.
Try to really get all of
this stuff out on the table
so you can be conscious
about the agreements
that you're making.
I think that would
be really useful.
AUDIENCE: Would
you happen to have
any advice for choosing a
partner in the first place
so that when problems do appear,
they're easier to work through?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
Great question.
I feel like my next
book, because my kids are
kind of getting to be
that age, is like, how
to choose a good partner.
Of course, my kids don't want
to hear from me about it, right?
I would say that the
most important thing--
I don't think it's
shared interests,
because actually you can bring
a lot of different interests.
And it's important to have
your own interests anyway.
I think sometimes people
think, well, we've
checked all the boxes on all
these compatibility things.
And I think that's beside
the point, actually.
I think it's about
emotional communication.
Obviously, it's about
the obvious things.
Attraction, and that you
find them fun and like being
around them, whatever.
Good if there's not a ton of
mental illness in their family,
just on a purely generic level.
But I would say that it's
about whether this person is
able to talk through problems.
And I wouldn't get married till
you've had some opportunities
to talk through problems.
Weddings are great opportunities
Just be willing to
like bag it if you
can't get through the problems.
But I think sometimes
people get together
with highly emotional, dramatic
people who sort of excite
them and activate
them, only to find out
later the person is a
total piece of work,
can't regulate their
emotions to save their life,
and is driving them
completely nuts.
So I would try to
really look at,
can this person
manage their emotions
and talk to me in any sort
of reasonable way about what
they feel?
And can I do the same?
So volatility, I think,
is something to avoid.
Addictions are
something to avoid.
I could go on and on, but
that would be my main advice.
AUDIENCE: So if you
have a couple where
both parties have a
tremendous amount in common
and just do everything
together, but then later on they
realize they do need to get a
life and sort of like cultivate
themselves, what do you
think a good framework
for that discussion would be?
How would the
couple find the ways
in which they can and
should develop themselves
in individual ways?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
So that's interesting.
I'm getting a feeling that that
question might have within it
something like one of the
people is feeling a little bit
of a need for more of that.
Because if both
people are feeling
like we just love doing
everything together
and have only shared
interests, I can't really
say that's a problem.
Life will introduce
difference over time.
It just will.
You might have different
parenting styles.
You might have different things
you like to do with the kids.
You might have different
families in different places
that you're visiting.
It will introduce it.
But say you're in
the early courtship.
You've been together
a while, and you just
love doing everything together.
That sounds great.
I think it's probably
more, though, when
one person is realizing it's
a little claustrophobic here.
It's a little too
much like this.
I need to have more outside.
And I think people in
certain relationships
feel very threatened
by individuality.
And I think that's
something to really take on.
I don't think it's a tenable
position in a long-term couple
to be like, you can't go
out with your friends,
or you can't go--
that's a problem.
It's important to hold a
space for something like,
I love doing
everything together.
We're incredibly compatible.
But sometimes I feel I just
want to get out and do stuff
with so-and-so, or go do this.
And I want that
to be OK with us.
I don't want it to feel unsafe.
I don't want it
to feel insecure.
I don't want you
to be too anxious.
Anxiety is a huge
thing in relationships.
And part of
relationships is working
through why you're
anxious, what can I
do to make you less anxious.
But claustrophobia and
having to always be together
is usually, over the
long haul, a problem.
So if I were the person
who was feeling like I just
want a little more
elbow room here,
I would just try to
introduce it as, I
think it would be really
healthy for our relationship.
Hey, let's read this book.
It says it would be healthy
for our relationship
to have a few things that
we do alone, just to have
more interests and more--
because as life goes
on, I see couples
who are in the middle of
life, and they're like,
our life's really boring
and understimulating.
Because I feel like my spouse
doesn't have any interests,
or they're always sort of
watching TV, or whatever.
So just talk about it
in terms of the benefit
to the relationship of bringing
more stuff in, I think,
might help.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering if you could
speak to living together
before marriage a little bit.
I'm in this situation where a
lot of my friends and people
I know who are in their
mid 20s out in Seattle,
they see living together before
marriage as a good trial period
to see what it's
going to be like to be
with this person for
the rest of your life.
But then, on the other side,
I have my parents and people
their age who say,
no, you can't do that,
because living together without
a bigger sense of commitment
just makes it too easy to
run away at the earliest
sign of trouble.
So I was wondering what
your thoughts were on that.
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Yeah,
that's a great question.
And I think the research on that
is kind of all over the map,
so I'm just going to
talk from my own gut,
kind of, about this.
I think that living
together will confront you
with the problems of
living, like someone said.
You'll have to work stuff out.
And that can actually
help you figure out,
can we work stuff out, right?
So that's on the plus side.
I think that on the
negative side is I--
now, at my age, looking back,
because some of my friends are
divorced, some aren't.
It does seem to me
that people kind of who
backed into relationships,
who weren't really
wild about this
person, who maybe felt
persuaded by the other person,
oh, let's live together.
We're not really marrying.
It's just a step to where--
if in your heart, you
don't feel like I really
want to be in this,
to live together
to see if you might then
be more in love, I think,
is a bad plan.
Because once your
lives are merged,
and then we bought furniture
together, and we have a dog,
it's so hard to ever really
see things clearly and say,
well, I got into this in a
sort of half-hearted way.
And now, how am I going
to possibly get out?
So I think it takes a real
reckoning with yourself.
Am I in love with this person?
Do I really want to
be with this person?
They may want to be with me more
than I want to be with them.
I've got to be truthful
about that now,
because it's going to
be way harder to get out
of it in five years.
So I think the parents
are thinking that way.
Whether you have a
marriage contract,
have a license, in
my mind, who cares.
But if your emotional
feeling is not
that this is really the one,
I think it can be very costly.
And more costly to women, just
in terms of biological clock,
frankly.
My daughter I would
be more worried
about moving in with someone
than my son, probably.
AUDIENCE: Should couples strive
for happiness or contentment
as individuals?
That was kind of
vague, so I don't
know if there's
really a distinction,
or it's just semantics.
What do you think?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
Well, so, wait,
when you say as individuals,
what does that mean?
AUDIENCE: I mean like,
I'm happy, I'm content.
She's happy, she's content.
We're good.
Is there a distinction there?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
You mean like, if we're
content with each
other, is that enough?
Is that what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, content with
our relationship, or our family,
or just happy about
the relationship.
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Well, right.
So this is so
fascinating, right?
Because we live in
this culture where
there's so much written
about being happy,
and there's sort of this
standard, like are you happy.
And then you feel like
you're falling short
if you just actually have
a calm, happy, [INAUDIBLE]
pleasant sane life.
Again, I'd almost say
it's similar to my answer
to the other person in terms of
do you feel something's missing
in some subjective sense.
I think some people are just
much calmer, much happier, much
more contented in a
domestic arrangement
where they get along.
And they appreciate that, and
they feel satisfied with that.
And other people need
a lot of excitement.
And it's sort of
knowing itself seems
to be the important
thing in terms
of what do I need in my life.
I have a friend whose son
just got married very young.
And basically, they
both just love nesting.
That's who they are.
They like a home.
They like being home together.
They like buying little
rugs and couches,
and that's who they are.
Other people would be like,
oh, I couldn't stand that.
I need to hike Mount
Everest or whatever.
So it really kind of depends
too on how you're made,
and how you're made together.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So while people are
dating, me or my friends
like to say comments on--
well, they're dating,
and say, oh, they're
totally for you.
Or like, no, they're no good.
You should totally
date somebody else.
But once they're
married, you sort of
don't have that kind
of conversation,
maybe because we're supposed
to forever hold our silence,
because we didn't
say anything thing.
Do you think that is OK?
Is that beneficial to just,
now that they're married,
just let them be?
Or if you do notice
something, I'll
be OK with them talking about
that spouse behind the back?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE:
Wait, so are you
saying should you say something
to the friend about her spouse,
or should the friend
say something to you
about her spouse?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
should we as friends
have a conversation at all
about other people's spouse?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Right.
So this is really interesting.
So I'm of the view that if
you have a close friend,
and you really have questions
about who they're with,
that you should talk
to them about it.
So we're talking before
they get married, right?
Before they make that decision?
I believe that.
Because I think who else is
necessarily going to say it?
And you know them, and you may
see something they don't see.
And in fact, I just
read a book that's
sort of about people who've been
married for a very long time,
and what advice they
give for younger people.
And one of the things they say
is, if your friends or family
are expressing doubts about
your partner, listen to them.
And the idea there is
that you may have--
because you're in
love or whatever,
you don't have as clear
a picture as they do.
And so the people you
trust, you should listen to.
And I thought that was
really good advice.
But I do think, and I talk
about this in my class
with these couples who are
having their first baby--
part of the issue when
you make a family,
and the little unit of
the couple and the child,
is you have to create a
certain boundary around that.
You have to have a
filter for the in-laws
and everybody else
weighing in, right?
And I do think it's
probably risky to a marriage
to feel like you have a closer
channel with your girlfriends
than your spouse, just in
terms of that family structure
and building something.
It can be a problem unto
itself if every time you're
having a fight
with your husband,
you're telling your best
girlfriend about it.
That doesn't create
trust with your husband.
But I think it's a really tricky
thing to navigate that shift,
right?
I mean, basically, it seems
to me when your friend says,
we decided to get married,
I would think it's time
to just stop weighing in.
But I would be inclined
also not to then continue
to have the same
kind of girlfriend
relationship about every
complaint she has about him.
I just think that's a
dividing line, in my mind.
AUDIENCE: One of
your earlier comments
around if there's that
one thing we take away.
And it was basically
like, self-awareness
was the thing that kind of
sets relationships apart.
And I guess my question is, what
happens when one partner brings
something up, and the other
person doesn't acknowledge it
as a problem?
So I have two specific examples.
So one, I don't know
if you've ever heard--
there's like a "New Yorker"
Harper's article on emotional
labor about how--
not to stereotype, but
like a lot of women
take on a lot of
planning for the family,
or doing certain little things,
or cleaning up a little bit.
And then a lot of
times, their spouses
don't consider those important,
so they don't consider it
something they need to do.
And another example,
I have some friends
that are having issues
with their in-laws.
So they have different opinions,
and they look to their husbands
for support.
And they don't get it, because
the husbands don't see it
as a problem.
So I guess
self-awareness is there,
but how do you address
if you don't even
see something as an issue?
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Right.
No, it's huge.
Those are both really,
really common things,
and really important things.
And not easy, obviously.
So I think I want to try to
answer it from two angles.
These are deeply
emotional issues,
division of labor and in-laws.
Sometimes when we don't
see eye to eye on them,
we try to just manage
our own feelings,
maybe suppress them, not voice
them, work around it, whatever.
But we come to a
point where we feel so
challenged by it that we might
express it in a very strong,
maybe negative way.
At which point the
partner is reacting
purely to the negativity,
and just then minimizes.
Basically, I see the
partner just trying
to survive emotionally.
Sort of like, tries
to shut you down,
because it's like, oh,
that's not a problem, that's
not a problem.
Which is basically
like, I don't want
to feel all the awful feelings
that talking about this
has created.
And then that person shuts
down, and then the other person
starts getting more
reactive and more upset.
So I just want to differentiate
the actual problem, which
are real problems
that need solutions,
from the process that gets
going when you can't find
common ground, or you
just feel like you
keep butting up against wall.
And what I'd like to suggest is
that, especially in these very
emotionally loaded issues,
you feel unapologetic
for your stance
and your emotions--
namely, in these
cases, it actually
is an unfair division
of emotional labor.
Or we're a family
unit now, and we
need to figure out a
functional way for us
to stand up to the in-laws.
Those are legitimate issues
that a person has every right
to demand a solution to.
And to keep that in
mind enough to say,
this is an issue that we need
to have as neutral as possible
a discussion on.
In other words, it's not all
about my reactivity to you.
It's about this isn't fair,
or this isn't working.
And then to go from
that, because really
what happens often is when
we're highly emotional,
the other person shuts
down because they're
reacting to our emotion.
So I feel like you have
to keep advocating,
keep bringing it to the table,
not be willing to be shut down
by, oh, this is just
you being emotional,
or you have a special
problem with my mother.
But just keep being the
rational, fair-minded person
that you are at work
to solve this problem.
And I think people don't
always think of it that way,
because it seems so
denuded of the emotion.
But I think that's actually--
Gottman, again, from
Washington, talks
about being as
neutral as possible
in talking about highly
emotional issues is key.
And I think what
happens sometimes
in these situations is people
are trying to emotionally
survive, so they start blaming
the other person for how they
feel, and minimizing.
And what's so hard and
challenging in that moment is
to say, I'm going to hold on.
I'm going to hold on
to my point of view.
I'm going to continue to
assert it in a calm way,
and I'm not going to
give up on this until we
come to a workable solution.
That takes fortitude, it takes
courage, it takes energy,
it takes all sorts of stuff.
But that's the basic stance,
I think, is important.
And I also think I
said this, but I'm just
going to say it again.
I don't believe it's
a tenable position
in a long-term marriage to say,
I don't want to talk about it.
You have to learn how
to talk about things.
And it's not OK for
the person saying,
why are you always
harping on this?
I do plenty around
here, or whatever it is.
That's not going to be the
end of that conversation.
You have to say, no,
it's a problem for me.
One thing I talk
about in my class
with the parents of babies to
be is you're the grownups now.
There's no parent
out there deciding
what's right and wrong,
and which sibling is right.
When you're a kid it's
like, you started it.
No, you started.
Oh, I don't care who started it.
You go to your room.
People can sometimes
have these sort
of sibling-esque kind
of ideas about there's
some right or wrong on high
that could be handed down.
All the marriage is about
is caring about each other,
and caring about each
other's feelings.
So if someone's minimizing
your feelings, saying,
well, I don't feel that
way, so it's not real,
that's not a stance
that is going to work
for you in the long haul.
The stance is, oh, I
don't see it that way.
I don't see my
mother as a problem.
But you do.
So let's try to figure this out
so that you're not suffering,
because you're my wife,
and I care about you.
That's where you're
trying to go here.
SPEAKER: So thank
you so, so much.
We greatly appreciate
your coming today.
DAPHNE DE MARNEFFE: Thank
you very much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]